the age of 56 the days are 44.
a clear decision in a divided chamber
donald trump will face a second
impeachment trial
the senate shall proceed with the trial
the senate vote affirmed that the trial
was constitutional
we will stop the steal
to make their case the democratic
prosecutor showed a video as
evidence of trump firing up his
supporters
ahead of the storming of the capital on
january 6.
and you can't vote on fraud and fraud
breaks up everything doesn't it
when you catch somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by
very different rules you ask what a high
crime and misdemeanor is under our
constitution
that's a high crime and misdemeanor
ahead of the vote republicans had argued
that trump could not be convicted once
out of office
this was dismissed by the prosecution
their argument is that if you commit an
impeachable offense
in your last few weeks in office you do
it with constitutional
impunity you get away with it
[Applause]
so recall trump's lawyers also resorted
to video
arguing that the trial was politically
motivated
and divisive on the impeachment donald
trump would you vote yesterday
i would vote yes i would vote i would
vote
with this trial you will open up new and
bigger wounds across the nation
for a great many americans see this
process for exactly what it is
a chance by a group of partisan
politicians
seeking to eliminate donald trump from
the american political scene
in a congress still reeling from last
month's events
it is partisan politics that makes it
very unlikely the prosecution will get
the two-thirds majority required
in the senate to convict trump
well what does it all mean so let's
bring in dws u.s analyst william
gluecroft william
how did this first session of trump's
second impeachment trial go
well we got a good preview of what the
trial itself is going to
be uh both sides arguing whether the
trial itself is even constitutional to
hold in the senate uh so arguing rather
technical grounds
uh we saw four hours of arguments in
total from both sides the house managers
who which is they act as the prosecution
these are democrats from the house who
are leading the prosecution case
and the lawyers from donald trump's side
now the trump defense is that it's
unconstitutional as we heard in the
report because donald trump is not in
office anymore that it's politically
motivated but of course democrats made
both a constitutional case and there's
also historical precedent for
exactly this situation that we're seeing
trying a former government official once
they're already out of office they made
that technical constitutional legal case
but also a very emotional case showing
video from that day of january 6
trying to stoke in the minds of the
senators especially republican senators
who are
much more skeptical much more on the
side of donald trump um
to remin remind them of that anger and
fear from that day
jamie raskin a democrat from maryland
who's leading this prosecution
whose son died just a week before
um those events on january 6. he had a
very
emotional statement to make and i think
we can have a listen to it
here i told her how sorry i was
and i promised her that it would not be
like this again
the next time she came back to the
capitol with me
and you know what she said she said dad
i don't want to come back to the capitol
of all the terrible brutal things i saw
and i heard on that day
and since then that one hit me the
hardest
but how much of an impact did this
speech and the video indeed
that raskin showed have on the lawmakers
well it was a very emotional moment
there's no denying that we just heard
jamie raskin referring to her his
daughter
who was with her with him on the day of
the attack again the family being
together still mourning the loss of
their son of
of her brother um just a week before
those attacks and then on that very day
the attack
happening the trump team the trump
defense team is very being very careful
not to
play down the events of january 6 in
fact admitting and acknowledging that it
was a horrible day for everyone
they're questioning uh who's to blame
for this that yes it was a terrible
event
and people need to be held accountable
but donald trump is not the one
responsible and as we saw by the vote
just yesterday on whether this trial is
even constitutional with just six
republicans breaking ranks and siding
with democrats saying that it was
gives us a good preview of what the
outcome of the trial overall is probably
going to be
talking about previous uh our votes
likely to fall along party lines in the
end which makes impeachment unlikely
yeah or exactly conviction they need
they need 17
democrats need 17 republican senators to
join them to make that 67
out of 100 senator mark to convict
a president and that is just unlikely
going to happen you might have some
republicans as we saw
in the vote yesterday on
constitutionality crossing lines
but generally republicans are very much
still in trump's camp
and what was very interesting about
yesterday's vote because it because it
was about constitutionality whether this
trial is constitutional
with so many republicans all but six
saying that it wasn't constitutional and
democrats saying that it was
that can only mean one of two things
either there's two
very divergent opinions in america right
now about what the constitution even
is and what america's constitutional
democracy is
or uh it says that uh republicans are
putting party
above the country and i think that vote
yesterday is quite an
interesting reflection on the state of
american politics today
william thank you very much